et cette polémique le manque de masques
et de matériel de protection plus
généralement france certaines usines
décide donc de réorienter leur
production c'est le cas de la société
dagoma qui a décidé de fabriquer des
visières avec son parc d'imprimantes 3d
reportage caroline billag et grégoire
douce et répondre aux besoins de
l'urgence sanitaire spécialisée dans la
fabrication d'imprimantes 3d
l'entreprise dagoma totalement changé sa
ligne de production habituelle depuis
quelques jours cette société de la
métropole lilloise mobilise désormais
tous ses outils de production pour
élaborer des vizirs de sécurité notre
travail quotidien
parce que d'habitude les machines qui
sont derrière moi elle fabrique des
imprimantes 3d on ne sait plus du tout
notre travail de fabriquer des
imprimantes 3d on est focalisé sur la
fabrication d'hier donc fait notre
appareil de production c'est notre
boutique production qu'on a mis au
service du pôle vie d'aujourd'hui est au
service des gens qui ont besoin de se
protéger et la celle à goma depuis
maintenant quelques jours on en produit
plus de nuit par jour et on va monter
encore la cadence de production pour
arriver à 20000 par semaine dago
m'avancer visière à prix coûtant à moins
de deux euros l'unité
une manière pour l'entreprise nordiste
de participer à l'effort collectif
ils nous ont fait la commande des
hôpitaux des cliniques des pharmacies
des entreprises qui sont au contact des
clients et du public qui ont besoin de
se protéger ou protéger leurs salariés
voilà en fait t'es toutes les personnes
qui ont un besoin de se protéger
aujourd'hui peuvent trouver une solution
sur notre site internet
aujourd'hui on a plus de 17000 visière a
livré dans le dans le plus des commandes
et toutes les heures
il ya des commandes qui arrive donc à un
réel besoin et nous faisons le maximum
pour pouvoir livrer tout le monde le
plus vite possible
si le produit n'est pas homologué c'est
la stratégie du mieux qu rien à prouver
par des équipes médicales qui est mise
en avant et ne le fera pas je m'explique
c'est une visière de protection s'étend
c'est un moindre mal c'est un meilleur
mieux mais ce n'est en aucun cas un
matériel
et médical qui est homologuée
pourquoi parce que les composantes nous
utilisons ne sont pas des composants de
grave l'ebita là d'accord
néanmoins on disait absolument
fonctionnel et pour en avoir discuté
avec beaucoup de médecins
c'est mieux de se protéger que de ne
rien avoir une initiative bienvenue en
cette période de crise sanitaire
alors que les critiques pleuvent sur le
gouvernement français
pointée du doigt en raison de la pénurie
de masques médicaux